>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, DC.
>> Johnny Tija: Very
good morning
to you all ladies and gentlemen.
I am Johnny Tija, I'm
represent Yayasan Sulinama,
Yayasan means basically
foundation in English,
it's in the NGO based in
Ambon, the province of Maluku,
the eastern part of Indonesia.
So, greetings from Indonesia.
First of all, we'd like to say
a very sincere thank you to you,
to the Library of Congress for
granting us this literacy award.
It's really a very big honor for
us and also a big encouragement
for us to continue our work,
especially in this kind
of multilingual setting
in this country.
And with this more
than 700 languages,
about 50% are still actively
spoken even by children.
And only about 10% of
the population grow
up speaking Indonesian,
their national language
as their modern tongue
or first language.
Whereas, the other 90% grow up
speaking their modern tongue,
which is different from
the national language.
So, children grow up speaking
in their modern tongue mostly
indigenous languages or kind
of a lingual franca
and they begin
to learn speaking
the national language
when they enter formal
schooling.
So, with this kind
of sociolinguistics issues
basically language becomes a
barrier when they are
entering formal schooling.
So, we try to -- we have
been trying to help them
with the language issue.
We started about 10 years ago
doing the modern tongue basic
education program in
the modern tongue.
So, we started in that
[inaudible] on the small island.
And until now we've been
developing teaching materials
in the five different
modern tongues.
And every year about 1,000
preschool children enjoy the
education in their
home language.
And for the last seven
years this impact
that we have been witnessing
that children actively engage
in the class activities.
They understand the
concepts easier and faster,
they're growing in
their confidence
and become more mature to
attend higher education.
And also, with the teachers
they are becoming confident
in teaching, the people
are more acknowledging them
and respecting them and they
are becoming skilled in leading
and managing the class.
And all the class activities
are done using the children's
modern tongue.
And we've been witnessing
really that language used
as medium instruction does
matter to the children
and also to the teachers.
The other thing is the teachers
need good teaching materials
in the modern tongue and
they also need training.
But training alone is not
enough they still need ongoing
mentoring and coaching.
And until now we've been still
doing advocacy on the importance
of basic education
and the importance
of using the modern tongue,
children's modern
tongue in the education.
And it's still a hard issue
actually there in Indonesia
because it's out
of the mainstream.
But we're getting
more political support
from the Indonesian government
and also, I might need
to also say thank
you to the government
of Finland they've been helping
us with financial support
for six years to
do these programs.
And the last thing is
children need reading materials
in their modern tongue and
also in the national language
to do some kind of [inaudible]
the national language before
or when they enter
their formal schooling.
And this year we've been
developing a children's book
with the help from the USAID
and thank you for United States
of America's government and with
a low-cost production approach.
I think that's all I
can share with you yeah.
Thank you.
>> Thank you.
>> This has been a
presentation of the Library
of Congress, visit
us at LOC.gov.